[Music]
time now for final exam where you pit
two News professionals here at Fox
against one another to determine who has
been paying closer attention to the news
of the past week our three-time
defending champion here for a fourth
week
Carly Shimkus fox news headlines 24/7
reporter and contributor to Bucks and
Friends our challenger this week a
perennial challenger Fox chief national
course big time was on the show last
night that has a very different context
you see no one has been able to stop
Carly so far okay
Petraeus the buzzards on tables you know
what they are right I asked the
questions the first one to buzz in gets
to answer you have to wait until I
finish the question in order to do that
every correct answer is worth the point
you get it wrong we subtract a point
best of 5 wins all right buddy I think
we can handle that all right we'll see
thank you here we go a 13 year old went
viral during Justin Timberlake's
halftime show the Super Bowl because he
seemed very distracted what was he doing
ed Henry he was on his phone he took a
selfie with Justin Timberlake but he
there was something he was watching a
video and it broke down or something so
he got teased well that's a long answer
and finding information
memes of 13-year old Ryan McKenna
stealing the spotlight poking fun at the
teenager for staring at his phone too
much while the popstar was right next to
him the kid should have taken this
selfie with Justin behind him and then
put his phone down and enjoy the show
that's like what we all do everyone's
got to have their phone and tape
everything well that's a very unclear
answer no I judges are saying it he got
it yes on his phone he said on Ellen or
Good Morning America that he was
watching a video and so you got teased
because the phone broke down so you're
watching both Ellen and yes ok let's
talk later good question to a world
leader made news this week when he
chastised a woman for using the phrase
mankind which is a sexist phrase in his
country this leader recommends more
inclusive
like people kind who was it wait she did
it
he had finished he finishes he judges
that would be Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau not Justin Timberlake
Justin Trudeau Justin Trudeau all right
we're gonna check the other JT the other
JT there we go
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau is really
serious about making Canadians watch
their language maternal love it's the
love that's going to change the future
of mankind
so we'd like you to look we like to say
people kind not necessarily mankind more
inclusive very inclusive yeah
so let me just say there are judges look
I'm not sure why they make the decisions
that they do but you don't ask those
kind of questions this is a very
hierarchical show the judges are in
charge there we go welcome one okay
certain number of challenges like I
don't I never challenge question three
which 77 year old lawmaker just set a
record for the longest continuous speech
in the history the House of
Representatives causing some of her
colleagues to doze off in their chairs
Carley Shimkus that would be Nancy
Pelosi and see Pelosi I don't think
she's 77 but we'll find out check the
tape in Nancy Pelosi whoa she punishes I
mean votes are the dreamers with a
marathon eight hour speech good for her
four-inch heels two blends has come
early even Democrats aren't happy with
the minority leaders performance one of
Nancy's colleagues fell asleep
Durham's no that's brutal that's
understandable right okay our judges
whose can see the sort of back end of
this and see the metrics say that you
you buzzed in just milliseconds before
you're out no no it does count it does
count but there was you know
wait so you could break the rules she's
fast all right question for sued one
billionaire Elon Musk just launched a
Tesla Roadster into space with an
astronaut mannequin in the driver's seat
because he can do literally whatever he
wants the Roadster has now gone off
track and is headed for the asteroid
belt but
was its original destination it Henry
Mars orbit around Mars Mars the orbit
around Mars alright let's check the tape
and just for fun the payload on this
test fly it was a brand new electric
Tesla Roadster which is now heading to
the Mars orbit a star man astronaut
dummy in the driver's seat back in three
tries to provide big news that is
corrected by the way our judges said
they admired the precision with which
you answer it Mars or the orbit this is
the third week in row that Carly has
come to a sudden death Wow
two two two winner of this takes the
award which has changes have alright
final question another example of tech
changing everything best buy the company
announced this week that they will no
longer be selling which music-related
product Wow and Henry CDs boy that's
pretty authoritative that would make
sense not 8tracks confident CDs
according to a report in billboard Best
Buy has just told music suppliers that
it will pull CDs from its stores come
July first
all right Wow so one era ends another
begins we have a new prize this is the
era of the do mug this has a picture of
Eric wemble of the Washington Post was a
guest on the show at one point here's
what happened to him but and then the
backside is my triumphant face so this
is very first day of it congratulations
thank you I will drink this with honor
thank you both that was great pay
attention all week final exams are over
now but next week we'll be back and you
can see if you can outwit our
contestants